our next talk benjamin Erickson with a
slightly different title rid of my
sports PCA thank you very much it's a
great pleasure to be here today I'm
going to talk about randomized vas PCA
this is joint work with my collaborators
pong and suffer both from the University
of Washington PCA is probably the most
important and most widely used
dimensionality reduction technique in
data science this is mainly because it's
very simple so the aim is to find a new
set of variables or uncorrelated
variables which account for most of the
variability in the data and we do this
by forming a weighted linear combination
of the original variables so in machine
learning we use often PCA as a black box
tool and that's fine to do there to
extract some features maybe which was
then subsequently used for
classification tasks but in some other
domains we want to use PCA to summarize
the data to to visualize the data and to
learn something about the coherent
structure which might be underlying of a
system and that might be difficult or
interpretation of the printer components
might be difficult if we have quite a
lot of variables because well what how
do you interpret the new principal
components which are weighted linear
combination of all the original
variables so it might be better to come
up with a more parsimonious model a
simpler model which is easier to
interpret and sparsity is a great tool
to to improve the interpret ability to
come up with a simpler model
often it is used to come up with a
better bias-variance tradeoff and as a
example here some climate data where we
extract on the top row see PCA modes
which are kind of global modes whereas
if we extracts fast PCA modes we see
that the modes are kind of more
localized and this might be easier to
interpret okay there is a there is a
well pieces passed PCA is a widely
studied problem and I do not try to
attempt to to summarize the whole
literature but I would start my
discussion here with the formulation by
su hasty and tippy Ronnie who formulates
past PCA as a regularized regression
type problem so we want to find weight
matrix is a sparse weight matrix feed
with a few active coefficients so that
we form the course was a new principal
component as a linear weighted
combination of only of some of the
original variables so this should be
then easier to give a meaningful
interpretation to the principal
components and how do we do this we do
this by augmenting objective with some
penalty which promotes some sparsity on
being okay there's a set up I hope it's
so far clear probably have seen this
before projection on the columns because
that's x times I minus VA transpose it's
sort of a projection on the columns
right but not quite yes so it's not so B
is not orthogonal anymore
so in the original problem formulation
be but VA and a has also normal columns
and it would be projection but now since
B is sparse it destroys the
orthogonality here so it's a it's an
approximation that's a trade-off between
sparsity and
me here that RFP so the RFP where our
sparsity promoting regularizer and
widely-used regularizer czar and the l1
norm lassoo or a combination of l1 l2
which is elastic net or a several show
later we can use also a zero okay so
this is a highly non convex problem but
we can use an alternating algorithm to
find a stationary point and the Iver
isn't proceeds as follows so we fix B
and update a so this involves oops this
invoice and or started going to
procrastination so basically we just
need to compute an SVD and then in the
second step we fix a and AB DV by
solving k k regularized regression
problems using a coordinate descent
algorithm or Lars okay so this algorithm
is not necessarily very scalable as I
show here so for a relatively small
problem I would say we try to extract
the dominant and sparse principal
components or compute these parts weight
vectors and we see kind of using
coordinate descent and spars we require
some quite quite some computational time
to converge so this motivated us to come
up with new algorithm embedding sparse
pca into the very projection framework
first and then in addition use some
randomized message to further accelerate
the algorithm okay
i will continue by first describing
sparse bc areas via very projection and
then talk more about randomized methods
just as a quick recap the very
projection as an algorithm from the
seventies which was mainly used to saw
of non linear least square problems and
has been more recently used also for
other problems like PDE constrained
optimization exponential fitting and the
idea is that we have an objective of the
following form here and we rewrite this
problem as a very function of the
ization problem and this is interesting
if we have an efficient routine to
compute a and as I seen before on the
previous slide we can efficiently
compute a because this has a closed form
solution here so let's use this idea and
recast sparse PCA as a sparse PCA value
function here and then project out a and
we come up with a new problem
formulation here ok so why is this a
good idea again
well we exploit here the efficiency of
updating a so I claim computing an SVD
cheap and then this algorithm rebalance
the work between the a and B updates so
well first it allows us to use any
proximal algorithm and I will not go
into the details about that here but we
can also consider robust loss function
to do robust sparse PCA and you will
find details about that and the
corresponding paper so you're minimizing
over program functions in the Farallon
will not make this yes yeah I will show
you the update rules ok so now what we
can for example update a using a proxy
radiant step here so the gradient of the
value function is simple to compute and
then once we have updated baby-soft just
procrastinating so that's a new i
recently proposed and well if you for
some more syria bout this i refer to the
paper i don't want to dwell too much on
that so we have the challenge if we have
to deal
a relatively big data and relative I
mean here compared to the computational
environment I have because I want to do
my computation menu on my laptop so 20
or 30 gigabyte data set might be already
big there do the computations okay
to quote run for no man truth it's much
too complicated or anything but
approximation so the question is how can
we get a good approximation to the right
problem and well we have heard a lot
about that we can use idea from
randomized numerical linear algebra to
turn a big data into a small data sketch
to solve as we have heard yesterday and
then use the smaller matrix to learn our
sparse sparse weight matrix okay this is
a sketch response PCA problem so we
sketch our input matrix X using this
sampling rescaling matrix so selecting
some rows or some eyes yes a few few
interesting rows from X or maybe
reformed some linear combination of some
of the rows to get X tilde so this is a
much smaller problem which we hopefully
can efficiently solve the matrix the
singular values and another yes so here
I have just be a transpose
yes so this is be a transpose so single
have alias what I mean I am NOT well I'm
not solving the SVD here right I don't
need to sing my baby yes
it's not smash TCA okay so the single of
alias if you if I bought right and if I
wrote right that so or my
principal component so this would be you
skate by the singular values right so
this would be another formulation here
but that's the same like x times you
want something in a portable right so
I'll put an extra x be no mind well my
so I want to have be easy modes to be
sparse so that I if I interpreted that
if I form that if you remember we said
my principal components and new
variables is a linear combination of x
times B right so B is now sparse so if I
take the first vector of it I form as a
sparse weighted linear combination of
the original variables so xB so that
it's not sparse the printer components
there's no I mean there are other
formulation I think where where they try
to make the prints components boss but
ok good no not a problem
ok so this would be I think well we're
not too much to tell about that but just
a quick recap I mean they're not sure or
quite many options how we can sketch can
use sampling or random projection I mean
we have heard a lot about this so
talking too much about it so let's see
how the performance is here for a little
toy problem where now the data are
generated from an underlying sparse
model we have 10,000 observations and
really as a sketching option whether use
uniform gaussian or count sketch does
not matter too much interestingly here
count sketch performs slightly better
even than as a deterministic approach
but that is a toy problem so let's look
to some real data that are kind of image
data and here try to compute the
Cave or kind of the top 15 sparse rates
vectors and here we see that kind of all
these sketched approaches converts to
another probably to another stationary
point obviously I could increase maybe
it's the amount of sketching here but
then the computational cost increase
rather see randomized SP smart PC a
formulation work which I talk on the
next slides about provides a near
optimal
of course summation okay so what do we
do well we follow here is a work by
Hiram artisan and trope and replace s by
by Q where Q is an basis function which
has all certain amounts and tries to
approximate the column space of our
input matrix X and well kkona has told
us about yesterday so you're probably
all familiar with it and the
optimization problem looks pretty much
the same like us before again it is a
much smaller problem to be solved still
I quickly repeat what we do here so
first we try to form randomly weighted
linear combination of the columns to
form a sketch and once we have this
sketch we just compute e QR to get the
awesome normal basis and as we have
heard yesterday also we normally try to
do some over sampling that we choose L a
little bit larger than the desired
target rank K okay in practice I do not
want to sample directly from X but I
compute a couple of additional power
iteration to drive the spectrum down so
a sample from a pre-processed matrix and
we all know we can efficiently compute
this using subspace iterations
and then at the end well I just uses
queue to project my input matrix to low
dimensional space okay how can we scale
this approach can I follow here loosely
the work by Gunnar and Sergey so we
could block our matrix X and then
compute a Cuby decomposition on every of
those blocks we can do the sequentially
or in a distributed fashion and then at
the end well I have my my piece here
which I can collect and stack them
together in a matrix K and then I
compute another cubie decomposition of
that and I get us an output this X here
which I then have us input to my spouse
PCA solver well I'm gonna told us
yesterday about the UTV's so there might
be actually a better approach meanwhile
to do this but anyway this works quite
nicely on my notebook just to show here
the advantage of using this blocked
scheme we have the randomized Pass PCA
which has a much higher peak memory
requirement about 6 gigabyte compared if
I use this blocked scheme I can I need
only somewhat below 4 gigabyte memory
over the whole runtime so I really can
scale my problem depending on my
computational environment I'm using ok
the only thing I need to be able to
access efficiently some of the rows in
the data matrix but it have the data in
a hierarchical data file formats and
this is not a problem
ok let's show me last couple of minutes
to to show an example you have seen at
the beginning already so we you see a
kind of the sea surface temperature data
or high resolution version of this where
we have the daily temperature
measurements at about 700 thousand
spatial grid points and we have those
measurements
available for the last 37 years so in
total we have a data set which is about
36 gigabyte big that is maybe not big
but it's too big to fit into my fast
memory on my notebook and a lot of these
boss PC a user want to do kind of their
computations well on their notebook they
don't know how to do distributed
computing or some other fancy scalable
stuff okay so here are the extracted
sparse PCA modes the top row shows if
the results if you use the elastic net
so again this is a one regularization
plus a little bit of rich and the button
we sees is zero net so that is L 0 plus
a 2 which leads to a slightly sparse a
solution but I think it seems to be that
the structure pops out to be a bit more
crisp and this mode here is known as the
answer mode which describe the the
famous VESA event called El Nino and La
Nina and if we just use this mode now to
form the corresponding principal
component we get something which looks
like this here so this is kind of
actually 12 months moving average over
the principal components and we see kind
of those sharp Peaks here which
corresponds to Z and in you a couple of
years ago it was a big an in you in the
late 90s and this was a strong and in
your event in the early 80s so well this
can be used to to understand climate
better and similar it can be used in
many other applications were supposed to
they can be used in many other
applications
to to get a kind of more interpretable
results the other example this would be
a flow behind a cylinder again we see on
the left hand side see PCA modes on the
right hand side sparse PCA modes which
kind of nicely contextualize the
coherent structure of this data set okay
let me sum up my talk so PCA is
certainly widely used to for data
analysis but in many applications we are
interested also in a better
interpretation in summarizing the data
and in this case bossed PCA might be a
valuable tool and if we are willing to
sacrifice some amount of accuracy then
we can use randomized methods in order
to explore large datasets you will find
software on my github repository in our
that's expose PCA package and in pison
within the ristretto package and the
corresponding paper is on archive
for a few questions
the have you have a pessimist behaves as
the iteration progresses performance
often what the smart specie about that
yes yes so how does the how does the
resultant improve as compared to always
there's a randomized approach with you
sorry yes yes yes so how does the
quality of the result improve along the
path of the iteration how many
iterations do you need does it help a
lot oh I you know I see I well okay
that's so impressed as well normally you
constrain it by your computational
budget you have so sales results I've
seen shown here last it's normally what
you get after a hundred hundred 150
iteration so it it should it should
flatten out in many cases depending on
the amount of sparsity you want to
introduce converters relatively quickly
but well you can you can define a
stopping criterium however you want to
define it right that depends on the well
on the task but I think in practice
quite often you you have a fixed number
of iteration and I mean I looked
obviously two different stopping points
and you don't see such a big difference
at least not by by numerical experience
with this I found it a little depressing
because that seemed like all the methods
I applied got the same amount of
variance no matter how fancy or simple
they were yeah so that's part of the
reason I was wondering whether it really
helps to like go to a on those I think
in in most cases not except you have
really tight exemplar you know the
ground truths and really want to need as
far as
unaligned coefficients but in a lot of
practical applications I think you don't
gain too much if you go another hundred
iterations
okay so yeah I have not shown this was
not true what to show if I show
objective whereas this time or whether
it eration so I choose kind of here's a
sketching amount so that that I shift
the same running times or that even the
randomized message was a little bit
better off the randomized message
because the randomize message I can go
very small if I have a target rank of
fifteen right there's a sketch rise is
25 basically what I did if I have 20
samples for over sampling so it's X is
very very thin and long sketching I need
normally a little bit more but obviously
sketching is faster so I tried to
balance this yeah but I have other plots
if you're interested I can show you a
choice of plots where but object us
where this running time with your isn't
how you solve the optimization with the
L co-regulation
this comes up I mean the proxy proxy or
Proxima massive czar allow me to do this
so kind this is widely studied so
they're kind of provided you're
relatively flexible frameworks that you
can just plug in whatever crocks you
want and then have a soft threshold or
hard threshold so l0 here - to be
specific it's just a half threshold and
then if you have 0 + air - this is a
scaled heart threshold so this is widely
started cess actually nothing fancy
about it too much
ok so so first of all I used I compute
it so what I showed here is Z Z sparse
weight vector just visualize so this is
kind of a column of B right and then I I
use this thus weight vectors I mean I
flatten it to form a linear combination
of all the original variables which are
kind of my measurements daily
measurements right and then I get a
principal component which basically
tells me something about it but I can
think about this as a temporal mode
which tells me how this mode various
over time and that's what I have plotted
basically here the only thing to make
the plot a little bit neither I have
taken a twelve-months moving average
over the principal components or over
the temporal modes time or kind of this
kind of the motes and aside you just see
kind of earthy the coefficients
temperature it's not it's not it's not
really well I mean I could not well the
deviation I could say yeah
I mean bit careful because I mean
obviously I'm not in the original space
where temperature anymore but yeah yeah
we've just said so it's kind of a zcz
deviation like if this this event here
is has a well it's large so it's popping
up or if it's not basically at a time
not not yet has increased relatively
small aperture hmm yeah yeah so in a
certain sense that's the increasing
decreasing temperature just I would not
say this exactly is on a temperature
scale anymore right because I'm in a
rotated space but in a certain sense yes
that was it maybe yeah I should say this
so I should say so yeah so I know if
there's a peak here then as the
temperature a sea surface temperature is
extremely warm in this region which
corresponds to Z and in your event and
at some points it is much cooler and
this corresponds to a La Nina event
all right
[Applause]